good evening unvaccinated teachers have
to get tested for cobit and it's causing
some long lines thanks for joining us
here at six i'm denise faldis and i'm
brian loftis these are eight
separate testing locations in the
district sending staffer students if
they need a cova destinies
yeah madison kimbrough was at the
location at mohave high school in north
las vegas where the line was very long
this afternoon madison
earlier this evening this whole area was
filled with ccsd staff
you can see we're here at mohave high
school this is considered the designated
spot for region 1 staff to get tested
take a look at this video that was sent
to us by a teacher
of unvaccinated ccsd staff waiting in
line for covet testing
ccsd rules say if you are not vaccinated
you have to get weekly testing and if
you don't comply then you don't work
several ccsd employees fuming over the
conditions
of having to wait out in the sun without
any water or shade
and we were told by one teacher that
this is all on their personal time to
get tested
during after school hours currently as
you can see there is no line here
really nothing going on due to officials
and police turning people away
due to the lack of tests available but
coming up we will make sure to talk to
more ccsd staff along with the president
of the teachers union to get more
information on this whole debacle that
happened earlier today
reporting live madison kimbrough 8 news
now